hello everyone
scp049 here
back with another episode
of surgeon simulator anniversary edition
i have been absent for a long time so
this is going to be quite hard to get
used to after a while
so what i'm going to do here is just
try and play this tape just to get
myself used to playing again
if it would stay in my hand
be good
[Applause]
um
that was quite an explosive reaction i
didn't expect that
okay
let's see
press forward
again
i
didn't mean to do that
again
is that darth vader
sounds very like
it's bubbling
oh
all right i think this is just
the sound yeah it's just the soundtrack
oh well
i think we've gotten to the end of it
anyway
anyway thought that would have been a
nice easter egg
so today i'm going to be playing
teeth transplant
i have had some practice before
but i haven't played it in months so
i can assure you i won't be in the least
bit good
at this today
right
so
okay
i think
the first thing
i need to do is
get us
get a scalpel
scalpel is what i need here
[Music]
just to make it a little bit easier to
manage
just
pick it up
even the simplest things i'm finding
extremely difficult for some reason
okay
so just
ever so slightly
well that went well i'm not used to that
going so well
seconds oh
sorry there
i keep on stabbing you in the face
completely unintentional i there we go
finally
he is
maskless
oh
[Music]
he seems to have a have a rather
unsightly moustache
but luckily i remember
you can actually shave it off
with this peculiar looking contraction
now i don't know about you but i
just can't help but shake the feeling
that
this moustache
is just it just looks like a massive
eyebrow
in the middle of
his face it's just incredibly
disconcerting
incredibly so
so if i could just get rid of this
i think it'll make
the general transplant a lot more
pleasant really
now i have to apologize i seem to be
shaving
i hit the moustache which
isn't
my intention
[Music]
hold on
let's do it again
the other
[Music]
a side of hair seems to be flying off
but his face doesn't seem to be
it's a little bit better
any closer and i seem to be trimming as
long as it has
[Music]
i don't seem to be able to get it
extremely awkward
[Music]
come on
that's always the last little
fiddly bits
and
looks like he has a mole
very confusing
[Music]
okay
doesn't look like i'm gonna get any
further with that but
he does look slightly better anyway i
digress
this is where the surgery starts
i'm just going to move
remove rather these top two
teeth um
i seem to have removed
a good
two sparks
[Music]
there's one
so if i could just get the one
to my right has left
that would be good
there we go good
okay
oh almost filled this
george's torso there that's obviously
not what i wanted to do either
now let's see if i can
get this
bottom left
without getting any
[Music]
seem to be losing my skill search and
simulator
to be fair i am not a dentist
and there it is okay
so i'm never going to be using this
drill again so i think it's safe to
throw away
so next to paul i think we need a yes
we need these
just clear the desk here
just open these
[Music]
sorry i'm just thinking out
i'm going to take these out um
i think i could just use this my finger
didn't i
seem to be locking up
okay
this is quite frustrating i'm just going
to leave these tweezers here
first of all i'm going to grab this b
i'm going to grab this beaker
because it seems to be doing nothing
being in the way
and
i'm going to grab the doors
and simply just rip them off because
i don't need them
just throw that one away
grab the middle one
and throw that away as well
i'm not going to bother with the left
one
because frankly
the grinders are at the back and none of
my teeth are at the back
or should i say none of the teeth that i
need to replace are at the back
just gradually
put it in there there we go there's one
unfortunately there really is nothing
you can do to orient the teeth
to make them
more suitable
and it's quite frustrating
because they don't look very good do
they i wouldn't be very happy
with that myself
[Music]
okay
if i could
just get this in
this is confusing
this seems to be there
this is
[Music]
till sticks i seem to adopt it
in his mouth
[Music]
just put it
in
his
finally
well that was a relief
so
that's the teeth transplant
i hope you will enjoy this episode and
as always
i am the cure
you